[Musique]
au plus fort de la crise sanitaire
ils étaient déjà en grande difficulté
aujourd'hui avec l'inflation le coût de
la vie pour les étudiants a augmenté de
plus de 6% en un an
2022 avec
l'inflation compte certains facteurs
qu'on prenait pas en compte avant ça
devient de plus en plus compliqué
[Musique]
on cherche surtout à faire en sorte de
tenir le coup et de d'avoir de quoi
tenir au moins au moins semestre au
moins l'année
même en travaillant
les fins de mois sont difficiles on vit
pas en survie
[Musique]
chaque mois pour Mandy 21 ans c'est le
même rituel quand elle ne révise pas
cette étudiante en deuxième année de
droit à Orléans fait ses comptes une
nécessité depuis que l'inflation s'élève
à plus de 6%. ici je vais avoir le
salaire que j'ai reçu donc ça c'est
vraiment ce que j'ai pu percevoir ce
mois-ci avec la fiche de paie
j'épargnais 100 euros de côté comme ça
je suis sûr que si j'ai un imprévu ou
pour l'avenir encore une fois je peux
mettre de côté les parents je leur ai
versé de l'argent pour le loyer si je
n'ai pas un regard sur mes revenus enfin
sur mes dépenses je vais faire n'importe
quoi et là c'est la catastrophe même
avec l'aide financière de ses parents
mandy est obligé de se restreindre sur
ses dépenses alimentaires
donc là voilà on peut remarquer que mon
frigo il est assez vide parce que tout
simplement je fais mes achats au jour le
jour quand j'ai besoin de quelque chose
donc jusqu'à présent il me reste de
l'eau et du jus d'orange même pas c'est
un jus de fruits pour boire le matin et
si j'estime que j'en ai plus assez ou
que j'en aurai besoin le lendemain je
vais y aller le jour même je fais pas
forcément trois repas par jour parce que
j'ai pas forcément faim ou temps en
temps c'est parce que je vais pas avoir
le choix je vais avoir faim mais je vais
me dire non tu attends ce soir comme ça
c'est parfait
[Musique]
se nourrir c'est aussi une préoccupation
pour Laura étudiante en psychologie à
Tours dans les allées du marché Saint
Paul elle commence par un repérage des
étals et qu'on part tous les prix
le raisin pareil c'est cette huile et à
tout à l'heure il était à 2,40
[Musique]
cette relation avec le commerçant et
des fois en plus quand on fait partie
avec eux ils connaissent la situation
donc
ils sont sympas quoi et on peut faire
aussi les fins de marché pour avoir mal
les restes et c'est pareil on les paye
moins cher
l'augmentation du coût de la vie à
diviser son budget alimentaire par deux
désormais elle fait l'impasse sur
certains produits
la viande j'en prends pas pour ça coûte
trop cher ou alors très rarement il faut
que ce soit en promotion ou là j'en ai
acheté récemment mais parce que il y en
avait il y avait 12 gouttes de porc à
pour 11 euros donc c'est en fait ça
revenait à moins de de 1 euro la côte du
coup je les congèle et ça me dure
pendant deux trois mois quoi
[Musique]
fin de journée sur le campus d'Orléans
Élodie 19 ans récupère son dîner au
restaurant du CROUS
bonjour bonjour Chaque jour elle vient
chercher un repas complet pour un euro
au lieu de 3,30 €
surtout dans les courses
ça devient très compliqué
je vois pas comment je pourrais faire
d'autre parce que j'ai les sens à payer
à côté j'ai tous les autres frais alors
je me dis que si j'ai pas le repas en
euros je suis je suis très mal
depuis trois ans ils sont 20.000
boursiers à en bénéficier sur l'académie
d'Orléans-Tours
et je vois des produits que je prenais
l'année dernière qui était à moins d'un
euro et là ils sont en 5 ans ou même un
petit peu plus ça fait un peu mal je me
dis que vaut mieux presque je mange au
CROUS tous les jours et puis ça me
revient moins cher quoi
malgré ses difficultés Élodie refuse
pour le moment de se rendre à une
distribution alimentaire
je sais qu'il y en a qui sont encore
plus touchés que moi et
je me dis que d'abord c'est c'est à eux
d'avoir ses aides et que moi si j'en ai
si j'en ai vraiment besoin gérer les
demander mais pour l'instant ça se passe
pas
Mandy elle peut compter sur sa meilleure
amie pour la dépanner
Alexandra elle aussi étudiante en droit
lui apporte quelques courses de temps en
temps
un paquet de pâtes en plus c'est les
coquillettes
encore chez ses parents
[Musique]
les deux amis ne se connaissent que
depuis un an
je vais pas la même situation après
j'essaie de me mettre à sa place et de
me dire que elle est forte parce que moi
sa place je sais pas si j'aurais la
force de faire un tableau Excel de
travailler en même temps de enfin c'est
à l'appui elle a pas on va dire ce qui
est ses parents sont loin donc elle a
pas le soutien que moi j'ai de mes
parents donc ouais franchement j'admire
beaucoup sur ça
franchement mentalement ça fait ça fait
du bien de pouvoir compter sur ses amis
si ça va pas bon écoute j'ai besoin de
te voir parce que je vis une période
difficile et ça fait du bien ça fait du
bien
[Musique]
Laura de son côté trouve aussi du
réconfort auprès de Néo
son furet de 2 ans
toute la semaine même des fois pendant
plusieurs mois du coup bah
il joue avec moi donc c'est mieux elle
voit rarement ses parents qui vivent à
Nantes car elle n'a pas assez d'argent
pour faire des allers-retours
issu d'un milieu modeste elle assume
seul toutes ses charges
je peux pas leur faire porter le poids
d'un choix qui revient qu'à moi d'avoir
pris mes études sur le tard surtout que
je suis partie loin du coup bah je me
sens responsable je me sens l'envie
d'assumer le totalement mais c'est vrai
que c'est pas simple quoi alors pour
s'en sortir les économies ne se font pas
que sur la nourriture
mais pas très bien isolé donc pour bien
isoler la pièce à vivre et avoir un peu
plus chaud l'hiver parce que c'est très
très humide chez moi et du coup je suis
obligé de diminuer le chauffage à cause
des augmentations de l'électricité il y
a pas de petites économies je sais que
je fais tout le temps attention à la
lumière quand je quitte une pièce
l'ordinateur si j'utilise plus je le
coupe tout de suite c'est plein de
petits de petites débrouilles qui
cumulés font qu'on gagne
quelques euros quoi
mais dans certains cas difficile de
faire autrement
à Orléans Élodie est obligé d'utiliser
sa voiture pour se rendre à ses cours de
STAPS
c'est essentiellement centré sur le
sport avec
de la pratique et des fois c'est pas sur
la fac c'est ça le problème
moi mes cours de foot c'est c'est le
mardi j'en ai deux différents du coup je
dois faire un aller-retour le matin et
un aller-retour l'après-midi ça fait que
au bout d'un moment ça
fait beaucoup d'essence utilisé pour une
journée plus ça va et plus c'est
compliqué
les sens qui augmentent ça fait que au
bout d'un moment je vais plus pouvoir
tout assumer seul
Élodie vie grâce à sa bourse 270 euros
par mois et sur les économies faites
grâce à un job d'été
heureusement le jeudi soir il y a foot
avec les copines
nous savons qu'il est un moment de
détente loin des soucis financiers
[Musique]
pas de loisir pour Laura qui fait le
ménage chez son voisin René
84 ans
l'étudiante optimise tout son temps
libre pour gagner un peu d'argent
en ce moment j'ai deux travail parce que
j'ai pas cours donc j'essaie de cumuler
deux travail chez Leclerc et chez
Decathlon j'aide René de temps en temps
je garde aussi des chiens à la maison
régulièrement voilà cette année je
redouble entre autres à cause de ça
parce que j'ai eu un planning l'année
dernière trop condensé c'était trop
compliqué je faisais des journées je
partais de chez moi il était 7h30 je
rentrais il était 21h tu veux que je
passe quand pour les courses
cet après-midi non ben non du coup je
peux pas demain
demain après-midi si tu veux
quoi
d'argent pour les tâches ménagères et
cet hiver il l'aidera aussi à payer ses
factures d'électricité
je pense que le rap il y a beaucoup
d'étudiants comme elle
mais il y a des étudiants qui disent
rien qui vivent dans une pauvreté qui
sont donc obligés d'aller au restaurant
du coeur les étudiants sont tombés sur
le bord de la route on les a laissés
d'abord tous les jeunes on les a laissé
sur le bord de la route on les laisse on
s'en occupe pas comme des personnes
âgées
au revoir bonne nuit à demain
[Musique]
mais la vie étudiante c'est aussi
pouvoir profiter de sa jeunesse une expo
une séance de cinéma un bon verre en
terrasse avec ses amis encore faut-il
pouvoir se les payer faute d'argent
Élodie elle s'est trouvé un passe-temps
favori qui a l'avantage d'être gratuit
préfère privilégier tout ce qui est
marche des trucs où on n'a pas payé quoi
genre le cinéma on évite ou très peu
quoi la plupart du temps les gens on
leur dit viens viens on va marcher on va
faire un tour ils sont là moins non moi
je préférerais aller regarder un film
faire un bowling des trucs comme ça un
truc dynamique amusant et tout mais oui
mais moi je peux pas
[Musique]
Élodie Laura Mandy continue de
s'accrocher malgré la galère et les
incertitudes
[Musique]
j'ai pas envie d'avoir un métier qui me
plaît pas pour survivre je préfère
autant survivre avec un métier qui me
plaît et du coup bah c'est ça qui me
tient ouais à l'heure actuelle c'est
de viser quelque chose que j'ai envie de
faire on n'est jamais certain d'avoir
entre guillemets un bon travail après
nos études on peut faire 5 ans d'études
et puis gagner le SMIC par la suite et
je trouve ça
démotivant survivre réussir à tenir pour
après avoir un travail où on gagne assez
où on est heureux mais
sans un peu seul des fois
selon un rapport de lunettes paru en
2019 20% des étudiants vivent en dessous
du seuil de pauvreté en 2022 ils sont
parmi les premières victimes de
l'inflation
[Musique]